[Music]
dreamers are driven by determination
while ters are part by risk-taking I'm
someone who prioritizes mental health
and therefore juggling motherhood
marriage upskilling along with the
full-time job seemed to upset the same
at the time I also felt the need to grow
professionally but it seemed impossible
with my
responsibilities I had two options
either compromise on my career growth
and delay my upskilling or take a risk
by quitting my job to focus on my child
along with the much needed upskilling I
took the risk with a six-month career
Gap to upskill in the data analytics
program with simply learn I successfully
changed my domain with a substantial
salary hike hi I'm aransa Anthony I live
in Delhi I hold a BC in mathematics and
have completed my MBA in retail
management after my MBA in 2015 I
started working for a retail Giant in
the operations domain in 2022 I felt a
strong desire to transition to the data
workstream as my education and expertise
was more suited there therefore I made a
decision to upskill but I had a lot on
my plate so I decided to take a risk I
quit my job and took a 6mon sabatical to
upskill after searching for a few
courses online I took up the
postgraduate program in data analytics
with simply learn one of the reasons to
do that was the good birth of mouth and
reviews from my peers most importantly
simply learn did not make tall claims
and Promises I believe no organization
can guarantee anyone's success but what
they can do is create the right
atmosphere and fulfill realistic
expectations which is exactly what
simply learned it for
me that trainers were were industry
experts with good domain expertise after
I completed the program I worked two
contractual jobs in the data science
domain for 3 months each and this gave
me a lot of
exposure finally opportunity knocked on
my front door my previous manager
contacted me for an opening in the data
work stream things worked out in my
favor upscaling in the post-graduate
program in data analytics became one of
the best decisions I made for myself I
rejoined my previous company after a
year with a huge salary hike and also
got the designation that I always
desired I like traveling and I also
enjoy cooking I believe in lifelong
learning and aim to improve my skills to
all the determined working women out
there taking risk and making their Mark
I wish you all the success let nothing
ever stop you from your
dreams